ouvert de forme depuis deux
mois jean ferrat et vision c'est le
moment d'investir 1,3 contrôler
l'industrie et pour l'innovation bram et
2 kg haut mais j'ai pas tout ça avec
zemmour vous remercie d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci ce soit votre
france au premier jour de votre élection
ça va être une france divisée où les
gens vont se détester n'est pas que les
mots laurent viel et gestes si oui parce
que via ce fameux doigt donnant rarement
la personne un président de la
république n'a été aussi violemment
attaqué pourquoi cette violence vous
l'avez dit exactement comme ça vous avez
10 non je n'ai pas dit ça vous êtes jugé
misogyne perçue par les français comme
sexistes vis-à-vis des femmes
aujourd'hui alors
c'est vrai qu'ils soient je comprends
tout à fait les critiques c'était
insupportable mais c'était insupportable
c'est surtout léa salamé je vous le dis
franchement oui mais elle n'a pas arrêté
de couper la parole presque d'invectivés
son rôle là c'est d'interviewer est là
éditorialisé on sent qu'elle déteste
zemmour et elle a rendu les missions
inaudible une matière à part dont j'ai
regardé en entier la détestation de
l'eat de léa salamé pour zemmour
vraiment est tellement visible
maintenant il est candidat on aime ou on
n'aime pas on le traite comme un
candidat on pose des questions comme les
candidats il fait 16 % c'est bien que
les gens qui veulent l'écouter on veut
l'écouter pour l'aimer ou ne pas l'aimer
mais faire un choix mais léa salamé
qu'elle s'amuse chez ruquier le samedi
soir pourquoi pas du divertissement la
solution politique donc on a rien à
faire de ces avis là ça devient vraiment
trop visible c'est gênant c'est parce
qu'on lui demande oui ils ont fait une
gilles bouleau c'était une interview à
charge du début à la fin j'ai mis
longtemps à gilles bouleau il avait fait
la même chose avec zemmour ils ont passé
à la loupe et la parole ils essaient de
le décrédibiliser ils ont commencé
l'émission en faisant un sondage en
disant voilà les français pensent que
vous êtes misogyne disons que pour
recevoir un candidat c'est pas top ils
vont là où ils se trompent ceux qui
pensent se faire et eczéma l'oralité lui
donne du crédit est un succès quand il
est attaqué qu'il est le meilleur hélas
ils se positionnent ils épient les
positionner en victime et je pense qu'il
ressent gagnant de ce débat éric les
débuts la fin quand le mec qui arrive à
la fin qui dit c'était très mauvais que
vous
sachiez aux pêcheurs et delphine ouais
en fait ils doivent être neutres c'est
très important parce qu'aujourd'hui
effectivement comme les remercier eric
zemmour est un candidat qu'on aime ou
qu'on n'aime pas alors on doit être
respectueux envers lui et envers les
gens qui veulent voter pour lui aussi
que madame wespiser
ses journalistes là doivent se comporter
équitablement en vert voilà avec nous
les avec tous les autres pays d'avancer
qu'ils ne se sont pas comportés
équitablement madame d'excusés non je
pense je jure que je suis fier
parce que tout simplement
ce que ce cas là mais pense ça
transpirait en fait dans les questions
qu'elle pose elle s'était totalement ça
vous gêne indom pospisil ça m'a gêné
aujourd'hui il faut respecter toutes les
valeurs sont pensés en france est tout
seul non non vous allez dire à niort non
non non merci je voudrais dire à dubaï
non moi j'ai trouvé ça bien j'ai trouvé
ça bien basse alors d'abord saisir
d'avoir quelqu'un qui dise que c'est
bien parce que d'abord zemmour on l'a vu
vraiment candidat on l'a pas vue comme
un polémiste trouve qu'il avait vraiment
on a vraiment vu le candidat zemmour
donc je serai selon fabien est en fait
le problème avec avec zemmour le
problème avec les candidats d'extrême
droite que ce soit marine le pen ou
zemmour c'est qu'en fait si jamais il ne
vaut pas que tu parles innovants
j'aime les gens tuent des gens
[Applaudissements]
il cavale vous allez je vous appelle
vraiment dans la semaine
moi je m'inscris je suis découragée
alevinages est bien là donc vous êtes
une suite à wii basse et les suceurs
fait un bon temps mais je reviendrai
d'habitude salamé a alors oui alors
compris l'autre si on est du côté de
zemmour ou si on est trop doux vitalité
zemmour on va dire qu'on fait de la
propagande bien mais on s'oppose à ces
mots on va dire qu'on est contre contre
zemmour contre ces idées et qu'on fait
de la propagande de l'autre côté on
connaît les aider à sa lame et lé cache
pas donc c'est pas une découverte moi je
trouve que c'est bien parce qu'elle
était plus facile justement lui il a pu
montrer qu'ils pouvaient se défendre
elle vient et surtout il aime l lamy et
ils l'ont mis face à ses contradictions
parce qu'il a quand même fait plein de
fake news d'hier et ça tout ça ça a été
démontée et je trouve que c'est très
bien ça fait avancer le débat parti je
t'appelle sur
les regarder la différence de traitement
avec bfm ils ont bien reçu de manière
équitable je pense que des chaînes comme
tf1 et france 2 ils ont un vrai problème
avec le fait qu'on peut leur accorder un
prêt et amérique zemmour il dit voilà
c'est chou on va lui donner du crédit je
pense aussi un brief oui mais sur la
raison 3 février sont problématiques ils
le savent je me domine oui et ça sent la
conférence de rédaction il dit voilà on
reçoit 0 on lui fait après que time et
soyez dur avec lui ne lui servait pas la
soupe et ça c'est un peut trouver à
l'antenne jeunes là où guillaume a
raison c'est que si on commence à dire
vous êtes racistes et misogynes de l'été
si vous avez ça ça va ça va ça va ça va
pas faire ça bfm il on a fait ça et vous
vous ferez pas ça gmail man on
a joué je savais c'est pareil pour
l'instant votre émission oui mais oui
voilà on a été vraiment voix soit joué
votre face à face à ce rachat sera en
direct on entend du sursis
m